one-man show you're you you did a
performance of it at rikers island
prison yes sir correct that's i feel
like i get i got to give back i got to
get back to you know i could have been
there so you know i go there i perform
and
how did now what
that
that's hard that's how i'd like yeah
you could have been in jail
but uh
somebody's prison [ __ ] uh-huh
well okay so you're doing a one-man show
at a prison yeah and this is a serious
prison exactly this
exactly this is serious prison you know
what i'm talking about
you bet i know you're telling me
you don't think i've gotten some stuff
in my day oh white collar crime
yeah i always spend my time in rikers uh
what uh so they have a lot of
restrictions man
you know i want to go give back to all
these kids and whatever and you know
they got you you're not allowed to use
vulgarity no misogyny no sexual content
they're afraid of you know
arousing the the guys and really yeah
so that basically leaves me like like
five minutes of material right
but i did it anyway and wait wait you
disregarded their rules you didn't you
didn't listen to them well i wasn't
really in jail i could do whatever i
want i mean
[Laughter]
and nothing happened there were no riots
they laughed and everything you know
yeah because my show it is kind of i
mean when i talk about sex it's not i
don't think i'm really sexy
but on broadway when i did it i mean
people were having sex in the bathroom
they would find i'm serious they would
find panties and
sexual toys and
are you i'm not making this up
you're doing this at a broadway theater
are you sure
it was it was the light ship theater
[Laughter]
all right there's a lot of stuff maybe
you mistakenly went into it yeah
it wasn't a theater with booths was it
okay it was your typical broadway house
it wasn't you know vaudeville or
whatever yeah
but i but okay so you did your show and
and there's a lot of people having sex
with nobody at the not at the prison
on broadway yeah okay
well they might be having sex in prison
i don't know i didn't stay long enough
to find out yeah no no you want to skip
that part
now let's change we're going to do a
we're going to do a 180 degree change of
topic here i'm with you on that because
you know where we are now comfortable
okay uh the white house you visited the
white house with your family
i told you it was a change of topic
i got it
[Applause]
smeared
turning this thing around that was like
a deposition question yeah
you were at the white house you were at
the white house with your family uh you
were invited there for the easter egg
yes the famous kind of iconic thing they
do at the white house oh my god i was so
excited beyond my i was so thrilled to
be there he's one of the greatest people
i've i've i've i just worship him in and
i and
it was crazy because i had to go to the
bathroom and i couldn't believe i was in
the white house bathroom with where
obama sits and cheney sat and all these
people and they have to wipe as well
it's me i i got a picture of him you
took a picture of the white house
i just think it's it's incredible you
know they said they're powerful people
they're really important but they have
to go to the bathroom too i just find
that really fascinating
oh maybe you don't but i do no no i
never have uh
never will i've heard tell
i'm hanging on just before i die